French Guiana has what is a rare wealth
in this day and age a natural wealth you
have to take to the air to get a measure
of it it is a stunning wilderness as yet
relatively untouched this is one of the
most forested territories on earth the
outer reaches of Amazonia the canopy
spreading apparently forever in all
directions there are a few roads into
the interior you travel by helicopter or
by water but that hasn't stopped people
getting in in search of wealth of
another kind beneath these trees there
lies gold lots of it and the price of
gold is high and that brings in the
carrying perros the illegal gold miners
we're in the air for just ten minutes
when we chant upon this a great scar in
the green and illicit gold mining
operation down below the miners see us
and scatter there's a futile attempt to
hide equipment here someone throwing a
water pump into a mining pool trees have
been ripped out and mercury used in the
mining process will have leached into
the soil and waterways most of the
miners cross illegally from Brazil trees
animals we fly on and see evidence of
more activity there are around 400
illegal mine sites in French Guiana
extracting an estimated 10 tons of gold
annually worth nearly half a billion
dollars on the ground of a scientific
research station we meet the head of
this French territory since he saw me
today Jean DOM a function elder law
Sabra Diez we have 600 soldiers
paramilitary police and other services
engaged daily in the fight against
illegal gold mining 200 of these mostly
soldiers police forestry and customs
agents sleep nightly in the forest they
lead patrols in small units of around 15
men
it's only when you enter the rainforest
and you see and hear all its tremendous
biodiversity that you really begin to
appreciate just what's at stake here the
tropics contains half the world's
biomass the rainforests a significant
proportion of that French Kiana's
rainforest remains an invaluable
resource
a rare mostly intact part of Amazonia
keeping it that way is the challenge
Nick lark al-jazeera French Guiana